Bish Ahmed survived Saudi a raids and
hthi snipers before getting on a boat
with her children her husband was a taxi
driver and they lost contact with each
other when the war broke out in Yemen
she has waited for a month to hear from
him after several unsuccessful attempts
she decided to flee with her children
she sold her jry to pay for the
dangerous journey to
jouti I was pregnant with this little
daughter I named her Gaza for months I
had no news from my husband then I found
him in this Camp he came to the camp
when he heard we left for obok I started
to work as a housekeeper in an orphanage
close to the camp one year later me and
my husband decided to open a small
restaurant in the camp this is bushra's
home and
restaurant she cooks and sells Yen food
to refugees to earn money for her family
her husband found a job in the city of
of jibou and he visits his family once a
month I feel like crying when I remember
sweet times in Yemen and I remember the
bitter memories too I lost family
members I lost
everything she says life in this refugee
camp is challenging but at least safe
thousands of yemenese have fled on small
unstable boats across the Babel mandab
Street they call it the Gate of tears
and name red from the long history of
people who have died trying to cross it
now more and more are embarking on a
dangerous journey to get here that is
because they fear the worst is yet to
come in
Yemen houthis in Yemen are attacking
commercial wessels in the Red Sea in a
show of solidarity with Palestinians in
Gaza and the US formed a multinational
task force to deter them there are
growing concerns that a war between the
two could break out any time
these Yemen family arrived a month ago
after houi attacks in the Red Sea they
feared us would retaliate and Target
houie positions in Yemen which can lead
to another
War I wanted to save my children the
most important thing is to keep them
safe the life in Yemen was difficult
there was no food no water we were
starving just war and more
war over a month ago a missile struck
their house in Yemen and their daughter
lost her
toe they don't have much here in this
camp but they say they can at least keep
their children
alive R Al jazer obok
jibou make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer